[Music]  you are in Philadelphia today is  Saturday your New Orleans Monday you are  in Kentucky this reminds me of the  documentary when you didn't have enough  time off and I'm worried about you how  are you handling a world tour and  American Idol at the same time well I'm  a bit single you know when you're single  you got a lot of time I'm just finding a  delicate balance these guys are pulling  a lot of the weight would you like to  get at the camera and make a bet right  now in this moment to Blake that you are  going to find the next country superstar  over what are we betting what are we  betting I'm not Blake I bet you four  horses  seven cows 14 deer stands and 45 acres  not the country Idol just the American  you see I can spot all forms of town  [Music]  you